no okay okay so you don't even know the
time period
s okay
so like factories came in the late 1800s
and still people still had five plus
kids early 1900s used to what was
traditional but here now the tradition
is having two or three you don't have to
have [__] ten kids and whose choice
is that it's ours as a whole we're
overpowered whose choices
just in general like you can't really
afford 10 kids right they cost a lot
more poor people have more kids than
rich people yeah
[Applause]
no wait wait wait wait who who who
controls access to sex men or women
women it's a women's fault not the men
unless they're a rapist which is very
good that doesn't happen a lot
if I pull the stats up
you're gonna say faster not only what's
been reported yeah exactly I do I do I
do understand what you're saying in the
perfect world if we have all these high
value men walking around we should be
here okay great no wait high value men
unfortunately don't well sorry I have to
say I'm not trying to uh interrupt you
uh so my mom did not raise me to be a
wife she was maybe be an independent
independent woman because she had dated
such terrible men that acted like they
were going to be this provider this
person got married to them or end up
having a kid and then all of a sudden
they were abusive alcoholics she's lying
this whole thing you know this is my
mom's experience and I know my mom is
not a liar
she's probably lying they usually lie
yeah no that's like because it's like
no no she'll say that no I'm not saying
it's your mom yeah but a lot of women
then you hear the other side of the
story
if it's more than one guy she's the
common denominator
is like [__] no I don't think it's
picker she's probably abusive like
because it's like what what do the women
do to bring this out of the men if it's
multiple men that means she's probably
doing something why why is it that like
you you feel that we're doing something
to Pro it's almost like it's almost like
what you're saying to me is like I walk
down the street just looking like this
when women get power we're not
benevolent when men get power they are
if if men wanted to we could all be sex
slaves in caves right now in cages
that's what happens when men get power
when women get power we tend to abuse
men we would destroy you has anyone how
are you going to make more men tell
because we have the [__] where you're
just gonna rape us and like just take
him
hold on hold on what she was saying is
who's going to take control in a
situation a man or a woman we can
overpower women physically we can
dominate if we wanted to so if we had if
we wanted to we could take control if
there was if there was physically right
yes not mentally so whatever so go in
your life go back to your statement
about it yeah because Matt when men get
power we're naturally benevolent when
women get power they're not and the
problem is we have an entire generation
of daughters and Sons that have been
told their dads were the bad guy and
usually they're not and I understand
that I do actually agree with that it's
happened my mom was actually really good
at like not instilling negative thoughts
about my father and allowing me to
understand how he was I think what Pearl
was saying and not to not to attack you
or your mom but if if in any situation
even a man if a guy's like oh I've been
in 20 relationships and all the women
were abusive it's like okay whoa what
did you do there's an exception but I've
seen ladies that have been in
relationships time and time and time
again and been physically abused and I'm
like okay first of all men generally
want to do that but that particular
woman she's doing something I'm not
agreeing I'm not justifying that the guy
should be physical but so 10 relation
hold on let me finish 10 relationships
what the [__] are you doing to cause
these men to get violent with you well I
think I'm not doing anything I'm not
doing anything no you are the problem
no I don't think no no no no well I'm
just thinking like like what okay so he
comes home and he just says I'm gonna
beat you there's no argument you weren't
trying to control him because I believe
the natural order of the world is God
men and women and when we try to confuse
women and say we're equal to men and
that we have an ability like that we
should be able to control men that's
when evil happens equality with men and
women at all right right but I think I
think we're supposed to I think we're
supposed to submit to men's Authority
and I think when we don't that's when
evil happens and so typically when when
there's a dysfunction in the family it's
because the woman was trying to impose
her will on the man look I I understand
what you're saying because I've been red
pilled like and I I'm 100 not a famous I
do believe in the red pill I think
you're a little bit more extreme in the
mentality of it hell yeah
that's my first
five four five four no job wow
I was making a lot of money for him yeah
but after school everything I wanted to
be better I did submit to him but he
didn't deserve it but I did and I did
start getting the disrespect I started
to disrespect him because he was not
met him but but that that's what go
ahead but listen so this is my first my
first thought when I was laying in bed
and I lost my job ended up going under
and I was like [__] like I have no money
to take care of this person next to me
and me if this house is burning down I'm
gonna have to put him on my back my dog
in my hand like save us both wow I was
like it was the biggest pressure I've
ever had and then I thought to myself if
I have to make this person my long-term
partner and get married correct what if
I what if I need to be bedridden with a
with a child he cannot take care of us
and he doesn't have that mentality of
you know what I'm gonna go shovel [__]
on the corner just to make sure that
this house is going to stay above her
head so I was like this is the most
stressful I've ever been I will never do
this again ever a day in my life so I
that day forward I understood the
dynamic between a man and a woman and
how I do want a man to make more money
or to be a little more responsible to be
very dominant but the the issue we have
with a lot of chicks is we're living
outside of our lifestyle means so like
when you have kids you're kind of
supposed to go down in lifestyle like I
have a friend she had poor kid kids and
she dated a guy that was making forty
five thousand dollars a year and she
relied on solely one income they only
had I know you see she's like oh my God
how would I do that
which is
no the problem is women typically don't
want to go down in lifestyle for a
family and that was expected before they
knew you'd have to work harder to have
like women would work jobs even like
with kids and they knew they would they
would get it they would get married and
they would like work harder and still
have less because they had kids but the
problem now is like women we we have
these unrealistic like lifestyle
expectations because we've been living
by ourselves for so long and I agree
because I was like you're providing
you're being what is it you're being the
man that you want in your life yeah so
you're providing for yourself and I I do
agree with that and I think my mentality
lately has like okay I'm trying to be
I'm very masculine of a woman and I know
this about myself but I don't want to be
that way right like I really am trying
to be more feminine with a man have him
have the dominant role be like and I
think sometimes with women like have you
guys ever done this where like you'll
date a guy that doesn't have a lot of
money or like the nice guy and you're
just trying to like beat the odds so
you're not trying to be a stereotype of
what women think using his potential
yeah and then you're like damn I got
[__] in my ass for this because okay
yeah
so then you end up becoming the other
stereotype where you're like I need to
date the guy that has more money or the
guy that does this or something well I
just wanted to say that um to your point
uh Pearl I understand back then family
was everything right and time has
changed to whereas though family is not
really a priority meaning that if you're
going through something with your
husband or maybe your boyfriend or
girlfriend you kind of keep it to
yourself because you don't want your
family or your friends to judge you and
you're making all of these huge
Decisions by yourself which is very hard
because you're not seeing it from
multiple uh perspective and again we
don't want our relationship Etc I don't
think it has to do with judgment though
because at the end of the day you have
to regulate how you feel about some
things no no what I'm talking about is a
support system so whereas though you
have a huge family you have a huge
support system maybe it is you know it
has to do with the church or with your
pastor Etc you have these people who can
counsel who can try to help you guys
before you do decide to say hey this
isn't working for whatever the reason
but today's society is more so who's on
my team yeah it's like oh I hate him you
hate him too or I hate her I you know
what I mean yeah so it's more so like
thinking about emotions instead of
thinking about the long-term effect of
if you do this you know the girls that
might say hey we're going to go slash
his tires you might have a crew of girls
that's down with that but nobody's
thinking logically like okay we can
slash his tires they're social medias
there's ring cameras there's this
there's that and we all can go to jail
and we may have kids that we're going to
leave behind so it's so like emotional
thinking well and and I think you're
right that's why I say like a hundred
years ago there was there was five kids
and so like they all had families and
you'd all like raise kids together and
it would be like a community but now
it's like we have so many single mothers
and single mother homes where it's like
we don't have that community and that
Council used to have and now women are
making decisions on their own and we
made the way and we make and we make
terrible mates so mate selection on our
own unfortunately something I want to
bring up and it's interesting and again
I'm not going against the women but have
you heard of one female rap artist
that is positive about men no no
what I mean unless there's conscious rat
you know let's say something you're
insane and so male's positive about
women exactly yeah so a lot of the music
of that same energy that's right that is
Queen Latifah said Who you calling a
[__] right now you and i-t-y
that's my point the culture and what
we're listening we got negative input
coming in we got people around us and
what happens is nobody is going to
anybody for guidance yeah on how to be
successful in what they want and it's
all about me me me right yeah and then
when you know who suffers the most is
the kids yeah the children yeah and then
they get raised and then there's these
problems and now what's happening is
there's no nuclear families anymore it's
almost a negative yeah right and it
should be a positive yeah you know and
there's so much like input like uh I
remember a long time ago I was like in a
relationship and then the guy put me in
my place because I was drinking too much
he had told me hey you need to slow down
and I think my friends had heard him say
that to me and I was like okay sorry and
then on the side he she messages me and
she goes wow you're gonna let him like
tell you what to do like that and
I think like a lot of like Dynamics
happen like that where we should be
listening because that's their partner
if if I was you don't know they don't
know the man that you know
it's a good influence the women only
that my friends owned her she's trying
to control you right
and the problem too is we have a
generation of really shitty wives
between the ages of like 35 to like 65
they're just not good wives and a lot of
them got divorced and a lot of them
didn't obey their husbands and a lot of
them didn't listen to their men and
didn't teach us what it meant to be
traditional because I I just don't see
modern relationships working I think if
you want to do it fine I got I got no
qualms doing what you want to do I just
don't see relationship like when there's
a kingdom right there's one king not two
if there's two kings they'd be fighting
all the time there's a reason there's
one and I think when there's two people
trying to have control and power all the
time someone has to give and
unfortunately nowadays it's more likely
to be the men because they're just
they're just tired of the women and
they're like a lot of guys will just
suffer yeah yeah there's a reason that
we have those phrases it's cheaper to
keep her because there's a bunch of guys
that they don't really have good wives
that we that we can learn from but
they're still married and it's just like
you know and they're and they're almost
like not even the king of their own
house as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible